the goal is to tell a story that has
multiple points of view for the very
reasons that we've been discussing and
to by doing so indicate on an artistic
level that the old idea of the single
even the old idea of the single author
if you will is flawed because it takes
ultimately many people to tell the story
of a community or the story of a society
so that sense of the August author who
can come in and speak for women and
speak for men I don't believe that is
what maybe your imagination is
sufficient maybe not you know my
imagination comes into play but before
doing that I would like to know how a
man feels or how another woman feels
about something I'm studying that
because I understand that I'm one human
being with a set of experiences that
color my lens and I've always been since
I was a little girl very interested in
how that person across the town across
the street how do they think and
understanding I could never think like
they think but wanting to try to do
something about that gap not even in a
humanistic way it was really something
that bothered me it was really something
I worried about so first of all I hope
that by being present as 46 people say
in Twilight to play about the los
angeles riots and playing a Korean woman
whose store was burned to the ground by
african-americans or playing one of the
african-american kids who beat up a
white man or playing Daryl gates the
very unpopular Chief of Police that it
suggests to an audience that they don't
have to sit in there one position and by
the way you know when I come out at the
end and take my curtain call I'm still
me so did I really lose anything no fact
maybe I gained something aesthetically
and artistically what I've been trying
to contribute is something about details
that you know maybe there's a wider
variety of human beings that we've
thought about and we can tell compelling
stories without having to have those
same stereotypes that we've been
thinking about over and over again